Now, this problem is more challenging. But we'll start it out just the same as
before. We'll change logarithmic form into exponential form. We'll have m as
our base, negative four as the exponent, and 1 16th as the result. So we know m
to the negative 4 equals 1 16th. Since we're looking for this base m, we want
this to look like something raised to the negative 4th power. If the powers
match, then we know what m is. Well, we can rewrite 1 16th as 16 to the
negative 1st power. Remember, a negative exponent makes a reciprocal. So 16 to
the negative 1 equals 1 16th. Now we can rewrite 16 as 2 to the 4th. We'll have
2 to the 4th, which is 16, raised to the negative 1st power. Now, we can
simplify this line. We know that when we raise a power to another power, we
really multiply them together. So, 2 to the 4th raised to the negative 1 equals
2 to the negative 4th. Now, this exponent and this exponent are the same. So,
we know that the bases must also be equal for these numbers to both be equal to
one another. This is how we get a value for m equal to positive 2. Nice
solving, if you got this correct. I know it was tough.